France 24 et RFI présente
[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour ici l'Europe en cette semaine qui
devait être profondément
franco-allemande mais en raison des
troubles en France le président Emmanuel
Macron a dû annuler sa visite d'État en
Allemagne une première visite hautement
protocolaire d'un chef d'État français
depuis plus de 20 ans les relations
entre les deux pays sont d'ailleurs
englués au niveau des rencontres de
travail mais aussi semer de malentendus
sur la défense la souveraineté
stratégique la diplomatie et même
l'écologie voilà pourquoi nous recevons
aujourd'hui une très bonne connaisseuse
du couple franco-allemand Franz
cabrander bonjour
vous êtes en direct en duplex de Berlin
avec nous secrétaire d'État auprès du
ministre allemand de l'économie Robert
abbek ancienne enfin député plus
exactement du bundestacks depuis 2013 et
membre des vers en quelque sorte vous
allez nous servir aujourd'hui de
thérapeute de couple alors avec toutes
ces brouilles c'est malentendus ou
est-ce qu'on en est proche du divorce
non évidemment que non nous avons
des temps en général qui sont difficiles
géopolitiquement avec une guerre en
Europe nous avons une tâche commune qui
est magnifique de créer une prospérité
plus durable mais qui est pas tout à
fait facile du coup nous avons aussi à
protéger nos démocraties à défendre bien
sûr les droits de l'homme du coup c'est
un projet commun mais difficile et du
coup on travaille énormément c'est ça le
couple franco-allemand c'est de
travailler ensemble avec dédicace sur
les difficultés pour trouver des
résolutions des solutions communes alors
l'annulation quand même d'une visite
d'État très attendue pour cause
d'émeutes en France comment les
Allemands ont vécu cela est-ce que ça
renvoie une image assez négative de la
France justement
c'était évidemment très dommage il y
avait beaucoup de préparation et
beaucoup de coeurs qui étaient mis dans
la préparation de de la visite du
président Macron mais c'était évidemment
compréhensible que dans une situation
telle le président ne pourra pas venir
en Allemagne et on regarde avec un
regard de souci notre voisin ça nous
préoccupe bien sûr de voir les
développements en France et on espère
que la France trouvera le moment d'un
calme d'une bonne réflexion et non-être
réflexion pour trouver une meilleure
cohésion sociétale en France et en
Europe alors revenons d'ailleurs sur les
différents et les maladresses il y a eu
un revirement spectaculaire du côté de
l'Elysée d'Emmanuel Macron justement
tout d'un coup les Français se disent
très favorables à l'adhésion de
l'Ukraine à l'OTAN ce qui n'était pas le
cas jusqu'à présent ça a pris un peu
Olaf scholls par surprise qui lui est
beaucoup plus réticent veut un temps
plus long et va le manifester d'ailleurs
au prochain sommet de l'OTAN à Vilnus
les 11 et 12 juillet là il y a
différents d'analyses
voyez vous avez dit votre introduction
qu'il y a des grands
désaccords sur souveraineté sur la
sécurité moi je vois ça d'un point de
vue différent quand je regarde les
débats qu'on a mené en France en
Allemagne sur les questions de la
stratégie de notre souveraineté
européenne pendant très longtemps
l'Allemagne a été réticente et n'en
voulait rien Macron pendant un moment a
dit que l'OTAN était mort cérébralement
et maintenant on a un gouvernement
allemand qui a dans son contrat de
coalition mie que la souveraineté
européenne était priorité du
gouvernement allemand et on a un
président français Macron maintenant qui
défend l'OTAN et veut même l'élargir du
coup c'est quand même quand on y regarde
c'est formidable qu'on a réussi à
quitter je veux dire le faux départ
entre soit de la souveraineté européenne
soit l'OTAN et de dire en fait
exactement les deux on crée notre
souveraineté en nous renforce les
Européens mais en même temps on va
rester des très bons et très approches à
Lyon des Américains du coup moi je vois
ça plutôt d'un œil positif même que si
on n'est pas encore tout à fait en
détail maintenant d'accord sur toutes
les positions alors vous parlez de
souveraineté européenne mais justement
est-ce que l'Allemagne à l'inverse n'a
pas surpris tout le monde et compris ils
sont partenaire français en proposant la
création d'un bouclier antimissiles
européens qu'elle prévoit d'équiper de
système américain et Israéliens donc
c'est pas du tout du bail Yolo pin actes
elle n'achète pas européen elle ne
participent pas à la relance de
l'industrie de la défense européenne en
tant que tel et ça évidemment c'est
peut-être contraire à cette idée de
souveraineté développée par Paris
non vous voyez nous avons finalement
décidé d'investir dans un Bouclier
européen c'est d'ailleurs avec beaucoup
pays européens et oui il est encore des
questions à résoudre entre la France et
l'Allemagne sur la pâtisserie française
mais est-ce que ça veut dire que si nous
en investit en Europe avec nos
partenaires européens que sur quelques
aspects on ne peut pas acheter le
meilleur la meilleure composante
américaine soit alien moi je pense que
ça ça se refaut il faut nous créer les
meilleures forces en Europe être
vraiment résilient et c'est un
formidable pas que l'Allemagne est prête
à investir à renouer avec ses
partenaires européens dans un tel projet
oui il est encore des questions à
résoudre avec la France entre ministre
de défense travaille là-dessus et je
suis convaincue qu'on arrivera un bon
résultat d'ailleurs le tandem
franco-allemand est constitué une vraie
masse critique 48% du PIB de la zone
euro 32% de sa population mais c'est
vrai économiquement
bon la France se porte pas si mal mais
elle a un endettement de 111% du Pipe
68% pour vous vous continuez à la
percevoir comme un comme un pays
dépensier
je pense que la France et l'Allemagne
des obstacles communs on va devenir plus
rapide on doit être plus souple pour nos
entreprises on doit mettre à leur porte
une main d'oeuvre qualifiée on doit
soutenir les processus pour la
transformation écologique et numérique
et je pense que ça sert à rien de se
reprocher l'un à l'autre qu'on n'est pas
parfait c'est vrai on a chaque de chaque
côté des tâches encore à résoudre nous
en ce moment on a aussi une phase
économiquement difficile après la guerre
ou après le gaz russe qui n'est plus
venu chez nous on a aussi un vrai souci
actuellement qui vient de notre trop
grande dépendance qu'on avait sur le gaz
russe et d'ailleurs c'est vrai que vous
êtes dans un gouvernement de coalition
vous êtes verte je le précise madame
Brantner mais il y a aussi et en
particulier pour tenir les cordons des
finances des libéraux qui ont qui
viennent de restaurer l'interdiction des
déficits et donc une austérité
financière véritablement à attendre de
l'Allemagne au moment où toute l'Europe
s'interroge sur les règles du pacte de
stabilité et de croissance les fameuses
règles de 60% du Pipe d'endettement et
3% de déficit et l'Allemagne s'oppose à
des trajectoires individualisées
et une révision des règles comme le
voudrait Paris
d'abord en ne s'oppose pas à des
trajectoires c'est une question
maintenant de quelle trajectoire quel
cadre pour ces trajectoires qui
surveille etc du coup c'est pas même
dans le principe qu'on est en désaccord
mais sur la question de la mise en
oeuvre et si vous me permettez je vous
dis très ouvertement que on avait un
gouverneur précédent qui n'en voulait
rien de
changement du pacte stabilité on a un
ministre actuel des finances du FTP des
libéraux qu'il en voulait rien il
voulait même pas toucher et maintenant
on a un positionnement constructif du
gouvernement allemand qui est prête à
s'engager dans une réforme c'est déjà
comme très très bien et maintenant on va
travailler sur les détails pour trouver
un accord commun je suis sûr qu'on y
arrivera alors on va prendre la
direction du nord de l'Europe si vous le
voulez bien en Suède le gouvernement a
condamné dimanche l'autodafé du Coran
devant la mosquée principale de
Stockholm le qualifiant d'actes ISL
homophobe une polémique qui a touché
finalement toute l'Europe et sur
laquelle revient Sophie samay quelque
pages d'un coran brûlé par un réfugié
irakien devant une mosquée de Suède et
c'est le monde musulman qui est en
colère depuis ce mercredi 28 juin date
des fées les réactions outrées
s'enchaînent forçant le gouvernement
suédois réagir si l'acte n'était pas
illégal et qu'il a été autorisé par la
police le ministère des Affaires
étrangères suédois le condamne fermement
le gouvernement suédois comprend bien
que les actislamophobes commis par des
individus lors des manifestations en
Suède puisse être offensant pour les
musulmans nous condamnons fermement ces
actes qui ne reflètent en aucun cas les
vues du gouvernement suédois il faut
dire que le geste a provoqué de nombreux
remous le 1er juillet dernier
l'Organisation de Coopération islamique
s'est réunie et demande à prévenir de
telles actes à l'avenir
et des mesures collectives pour empêcher
la reproduction
récurrente de telles actions
ignores
des manifestations se sont aussi
multipliées dans les pays musulmans
comme ici à Bagdad en Irak cette affront
au courant a provoqué l'indignation de
milliards de musulmans dans le monde une
insulte au Coran est une insulte à tous
les musulmans nous manifestons
aujourd'hui pour dénoncer cet acte et
appeler le gouvernement irakien à
prendre des mesures pour empêcher la
répétition de telles actes comme rompre
les relations diplomatiques ou
économiques avec la Suède ou tout autre
pays qui insulte le Coran ou l'islam
la Suède c'est aussi attirer les foudres
de la Turquie alors que Stockholm a
besoin de l'accord d'Ankara pour
finaliser son adhésion à l'OTAN adhésion
qui semble pour le moment compromise au
vu des mots très durs utilisés par
erdoan contre les Suédois
alors Francesca Brantner est-ce qu'on a
encore le droit de blasphémer en Europe
de de éventuellement de critiquer une
religion où s'arrête la liberté
d'expression c'est un thème vous le
savez très cher aux Français justement
oui je connais très bien le débat et
d'ailleurs intéressé
grand en Allemagne on a débattu beaucoup
de sujets les dernières semaines et ça
faisait partie des sujets qui étaient
pas des plus grands du coup c'est clair
que ça ne suscite pas le même les mêmes
émotions qu'en France et pour nous c'est
évidemment clair et important que on a
un État
laïc qui sauvegarde les droits de tous
ces citoyens aussi de ceux qui ne sont
pas croyants et après est-ce que c'est
une décision de gouvernement suédois on
sait très bien que l'extrême droite en
fait partie du coup c'est un choix d'un
gouvernement suédois on verra les
conséquences mais à chaque état de
décider de ses lois après je pense que
l'Europe a été important pour
garantir un cadre de droit pour tous les
Européens mais bien sûr pour les
croyants et les non-croyants alors
justement la Turquie de Récept
erdouane profite de cette autodafé du
Coran pour refuser encore plus ce
qu'elle faisait déjà à la Suède qui n'a
pas d'ailleurs livré les opposants
demandés par par la Turquie son entrée
dans l'OTAN dans l'Alliance atlantique
est-ce que c'est légitime est-ce que ce
véto turc vous paraît assez mal venu à
l'approche on le disait d'un grand
sommet de l'OTAN
nous voyons bien sûr que les
développements en Turquie avec aussi les
élections
menées à des complications qui restent
et entre page d'ailleurs je dirais c'est
pas une question seulement de la Suède
et une question pour l'Union européenne
en tant que tel nous voulons que la
Suède en tant que membre de l'Union
européenne puisse accéder à l'OTAN du
coup je pense qu'il faut le mettre dans
un cadre européen c'est pas la Suède
contre la Turquie c'est l'intérêt de
l'Union européenne que la Suède puisse
accéder le plus rapidement à l'OTAN
alors vous parliez de l'extrême droite
Francis cabrantenaire mais précisément
en Allemagne le 2 juillet un candidat
hanslot a remporté une petite mairie de
9000 habitants en sax analt et donc
devient mère permanent
l'extrême droite la FD donc est crédité
chez vous de 20% d'intention de vote
deux fois son score au législatif de
2021 qu'est-ce qui se passe exactement
outre-Rhin est-ce que il y a une montée
en puissance de l'ex Trême droite dont
on doit s'inquiéter
il faut s'inquiéter bien sûr de la
montée de l'extrême droite c'est quelque
chose qui me préoccupe et qui qui
m'inquiète et d'ailleurs je mets
beaucoup de mon travail tous les jours
à combattre je veux dire lamenter de
l'extrême droite pour défendre nos
démocraties et nos valeurs et je pense
qu'on va en ce moment pas seulement en
Allemagne mais en Europe c'est quand
qu'on est dans un moment de d'insécurité
que nous avons une guerre en Europe qui
touche l'Allemagne et encore un peu plus
que la France on a plus d'un million de
réfugiés de l'Ukraine on a une situation
de économiquement plus difficile à cause
voilà de du gaz russe qui ne vient plus
et que nous avons fait monter aussi les
prix énergétiques nous avons donc une
phase
géopolitiquement plus difficile mais
aussi une phase de transformation pour
arriver à avoir une économie qui ne veut
plus sur la destruction de la planète
c'est un processus mais qui est aussi
pas facile du coup si dans ce contexte
les acteurs démocratiques ne n'arrivent
pas à rassurer des citoyens que ces
procédures ces processus vont des
procédures inclus qui permettent à tous
de participer et s'il y a des acteurs
démocratiques qui jouent encore les
insultes insécurités pour augmenter leur
capital politique qui font le jeu des
populistes mais c'est là que les
populistes montent et du coup je pensais
une tâche de tous les parties
démocratiques de trouver un moyen de se
discuter sans augmenter les saints
sécurité et sans être populiste alors on
va parler aussi d'écologie c'est aussi
un thème qui qui différencie parfois les
Français et les Allemands le 12 juillet
en tout cas est très attendu au
Parlement européen le
vote en plénière de la fameuse loi sur
la restauration de la nature l'un des
textes désormais les plus controversés
du pacte vert Roger complet des propos
itions par les commissions pêche et les
commissions environnement la charge est
menée par la droite et l'extrême droite
là on est fait contre ce texte est-ce
que
l'appareil et Berlin sont prêts à
soutenir les forces supplémentaires sur
le pacte vert où vous avez des doutes
je suis très contente que nous avons
réussi à trouver un accord sur cette loi
au sein des États membres du coup entre
le gouvernement allemand et français
mais bien sûr aussi avec les autres sous
la présidence suédoise et c'est évident
que nous avons un état de notre nature
qu'il ne peut pas nous laisser froid il
faut protéger davantage nos campagnes et
nos bois notre eau c'est notre source de
vie et ça m'inquiète de voir que la
droite Parlement européen fait
maintenant l'alliance avec l'extrême
droite sur ce sujet au lieu de débattre
comme on le fait sur tous les autres
lois de la meilleure manière pour
trouver un accord européen et j'espère
que la droite revient au consensus
démocratique ou en se débattra on va
sûrement pas être toujours d'accord mais
on va trouver un accord et je pense
c'est ça qui est dans l'intérêt du
gouvernement français et allemand en ce
moment
merci Francis cabrantner d'avoir été
notre invité aujourd'hui merci à nos
téléspectateurs de nous avoir suivis
vous restez en notre compagnie nous
partons en direction du Parlement
européen l'été sera chaud chaud et nous
discutons de la possibilité de grands
incendies en Europe avec nos invités
tout de suite sur France 24 et Public
Sénat
merci de nous rejoindre depuis Bruxelles
ici au Parlement européen à l'aune d'un
été qui s'annonce d'ores et déjà
caniculaire comment l'Europe se
prépare-t-elle à faire face aux
incendies la situation est déjà
préoccupante dans plusieurs pays
européens et c'est le cas de l'Espagne
notamment qui fait face à une sécheresse
catastrophique le pays est déjà sur un
record de surface brûlée depuis le début
de l'année avec plus de 54 000 hectares
et ces trois fois plus que l'an dernier
sur la même période alors précisément
l'année dernière à travers toute
l'Europe 830 000 hectares ont été
dévastés soit la deuxième pierre année
depuis 2006 les dégâts sont estimés à
2,5 milliards d'euros l'Union européenne
tente depuis des années de mieux
coordonner à la renforcé ses moyens de
lutte contre les incendies en doublant
par exemple ça flotte qui compte
désormais 28 avions et hélicoptères
stationnés dans 10 pays pour la deuxième
année consécutive des centaines de
pompiers ont été
prépositionnées cette fois en Grèce en
France et au Portugal mais alors que le
changement climatique est une réalité
peut-on mieux prévenir pour ne pas
guérir bien entendre question nous
allons poser à nos trois invités
françaises
en région Occitanie dans le sud très
concerné donc un par la sécheresse et
les incendies et puis face à vous ma
ligne Bjork euro député suédoise la
gauche votre pays la Suède n'est plus
épargnée par les feux de forêt depuis
quelques années et puis avec nous aussi
Borja miguelès chef d'unité adjoint au
sein du centre de coordination de la
réaction d'urgence alors c'est
précisément cette solidarité européenne
qui s'organise est-ce que vous vous
préparez spécifiquement et comment pour
cette année on se prépare avec trois
activités essentielles d'un côté on veut
augmenter la capacité de notre flotte
d'avion et d'hélicoptère pour lutter
contre les incendies
après on fait doubler en deux ans
et ça c'est une flotte aérienne qui est
complémente celle de cet amende et on
l'a mobilise quand les capacités de
chaque pays sont en suffisantes pour
faire face à un février
après on a aussi et on est en train de
développer des activités plus innovantes
aussi comme les prépositions des
pompiers dans des différents pays
notamment cette année et Portugal France
et Grèce et ça ça permet un échange
d'ailleurs augmenter la capacité des
réponses merci un échange entre pompiers
européens pour connaître les différents
comportements de feu la façon de lutter
contre le feu donc augmenter les
capacités nationales et troisième on a
constitué aussi à Bruxelles une cellule
d'analyse et qui est composé par des
experts de cet amour en expert de la
France en expert de l'Espagne un expert
de plusieurs pays avec des expert S
scientifique et aussi notre propre staff
qui travaille 24 heures sur 7 pour avoir
un oeil très très ciblé sur l'effet
forêt des joints à septembre alors il
est l'union européenne elle a d'abord
compté sur la coordination et la bonne
volonté en solidaire des pays mais
finalement on a dû passer aux ressources
propres on l'entend parce que ça ne
fonctionnait pas pour lutter contre le
feu chacun un moment peut-être parfois
vous les gardez ces avions ces
hélicoptères par précaution on avait
aussi le sujet que Canadair ayant été
racheté par Bombardier la décision avait
été d'arrêter la production des avions
bombardiers d'eau et c'est grâce à la
commande passée par l'Union européenne
que la production a épu être relancée
donc on avait un parc d'avion qui
permettait d'intervenir qui était limité
aujourd'hui avec cette nouvelle
production industrielle on peut
réinvestir dans des avions mais aussi
maintenant on voit des hélicoptères qui
embarquent des charges plus lourdes qui
peuvent permettre de d'être beaucoup
plus plus en plus vite un incendie on a
un quart d'heure pour essayer de le
circonscrire et sinon ça devient un
incendie qui peut s'étendre donc le fait
d'avoir des des bons outils c'est
essentiel et c'est grâce à l'Union
européenne maligne Dior que dans votre
pays la Suède 2018 25000 hectares de
forêts
sont partis en fumée il y a une grande
opération européenne de protection
civile la plus grande jamais
menée avec des appoints du Danemark la
fin de la France la Norvège de
l'Allemagne et de la Pologne et puis
surtout c'était vraiment la première
fois qu'on pensait qu'un pays nordique
tout entier pouvait flamber non oui en
fait avant
dans les pays nordiques on n'a pas connu
ça comme ça et je pense que maintenant
les gens se rend vraiment compte de des
effets des changements climatiques parce
que c'est la combinaison de la
température beaucoup plus eau plus
beaucoup plus soutenu et la manque de
donc la sécheresse et ça ensemble fait
que on souhaite maintenant il a des
périodes on doit arrêter le tout les
travaux avec des machines dans les
forêts parce que tu peux avoir une
petite étincelle et hop ça part en feu
c'est une des grosses ressources en plus
la forêt là en fait je pense que nous on
suit de très près ce qui se passe au
niveau des développement des ressources
comment et comment on peut renforcer ça
mais il faut peut-être se pousser un peu
plus loin dans la dans la réflexion et
prévenir on va en parler mais en 2018
racontez-moi un peu comment l'Europe le
reste de l'Union européenne est venu au
chevet de la Suède qui brûlait des
pompiers il y avait du matériel il y
avait de de
savoir-faire qui qui sont venus et donc
finalement je veux dire ça a été une
catastrophe quand même mais on a pu un
peu limiter et je pense que
effectivement il y a un savoir-faire
dans d'autres Paris qui est nous on
n'avait pas développé en Suède avant
comme j'ai dit je pense que c'est un peu
triste de voir que quelques années par
après il manque quand même la volonté
politique de un peu s'adresser aux
problèmes de base quoi mais monsieur
comment se décide l'urgence des
intervenances et des interventions et la
répartition s'il y a plusieurs fronts du
feu par exemple si la graisse l'Italie
le Portugal brûle en même temps comment
on décide d'envoyer tel hélicoptère tel
avion est-ce que là va pas y avoir des
conflits
tout à fait et c'est précisément
l'exemple dont vous parlez avant les
moments où il y a des
concurrences pour pour les capacités
existantes c'est pour ça que la
Commission l'Union européenne a voulu
augmenter doubler la flotte des 28 pour
l'ensemble de l'Union européenne ça
paraît pas beaucoup
la cellule dont je vais vous parler
avant qui est une cellule experts elle
va coordonner elle va analyser la
situation en Europe elle va alerter il
va aussi coordonner les la mobilisation
de ces ressources en dépendant de la
gravité par un apport européen niveau
européen par rapport à cette gravité on
va déployer et des ressources qui sont
en proximité des ressources qui sont
disponibles on va devoir aussi des
mobiliser des ressources pour adresser
une
urgence plus grave ça se fait les
incendies les incendies ne connaissent
pas de frontières et les fumées
d'incendies non plus lorbude bleu des
pompiers c'est d'ailleurs l'eau est-ce
que il faudrait penser à une politique
européenne de restriction locale
européenne de de l'eau alors si on parle
spécifiquement du risque incendie mon
avis c'est que d'abord nous devons avoir
une politique européenne de prévention
et de sensibilisation aux risques 90%
des risques sont dus à la négligence
humaine par exemple en ce moment il y a
tout un tas de personnes qui veulent
faire des barbecues dans ma région un
barbecue en ce moment en Occitanie c'est
une amende de 150 euros parce que c'est
la première étincelle qui crée le risque
donc il y a tout un travail préparatoire
essentiel de formation aux risques après
l'eau pour circonscrire les incendies
donc on a effectivement des unités qui
sont mobilisées avec des astreintes dans
ma région nous sommes en risque incendie
tout au long de l'année 24/24 365 jours
par an ce que n'y était pas le cas il y
a une dizaine d'années donc ils sont
toujours présents avec des notamment sur
les aéroports des hélicoptères qui sont
prêts à partir avec une première tonne
d'eau pour essayer de d'être présent en
20 minutes mais il est sûr et certain
que en ce moment dans toute l'Occitanie
et j'étais en Haute-Garonne il y a pas
longtemps un des sujets pour les maires
c'était d'avoir des espèces de de
grosses tonnes d'eau et de les remplir
d'eau et donc par exemple la
réutilisation des eaux usées afin
d'utilisation pour les incendies c'est
un bon moyen il ne faut pas utiliser de
l'eau potable pour éteindre des
incendies vous parlez de prévention et
vous avez commencé à l'aborder ma ligne
bjor alors là on gère l'urgence mais ce
qu'il faut pas changer de paradigme
notamment en matière de gestion des
forêts de gestion des terres pour éviter
que les incendies démarre et se
propagent aussi facilement bah oui mais
justement moi j'ai l'impression quand
j'entends ça 26 avions au bain de 8
des pompiers ici et là c'est bien je
suis vraiment soutien cette solidarité
mais si on ose pas s'adresser aux
problèmes de base donc notamment le
changement climatique et la biodiversité
et la protection de la nature alors là
je pense que c'est comme avoir des
petites sparadraps pour pour un grand
blessure que fait l'Europe là dessus et
donc justement je pense que les
électeurs et les citoyens de l'Europe
ils voient que l'Europe peut faire
quelque chose ici parce que c'est
véritablement quelque chose qui ne
connaissent pas les front comme vous
avez dit et alors donc c'est très c'est
pas très très
utile quand il y a le président Macron
ou d'autres d'ailleurs où la droite ici
dans la maison au Parlement européen qui
disent que maintenant il faut un peu
qu'on freine tout le travail sur le
climat et la nature et la biodiversité
alors ça veut dire qu'on se tire une
balle
c'est vrai on par exemple la Loi sur la
conservation de la nature qui qui
prévoyait un certain nombre d'espaces
protégés
de plus petite parcelles et finalement
qui serait assez pare-feu tout cela a
été rejeté par d'ailleurs le Parlement
européen il y aurait un grand vote en
juillet on est en train de revenir un
peu en arrière sur cette idée d'urgence
climatique et d'urgence aussi à
restructurer l'agriculture je ne crois
pas c'est à dire que la phrase du
président Macron c'était de dire on a le
pacte vert on s'est engagé sur ce pacte
vert et on a des livrables et on va
aller au bout de ses livres une pause
environnementale du président Macron
mais le je verrai on va au bout du pacte
vert et cette pause environnementale
c'est de dire on en prend pas en plus et
notamment sur le risque incendie quand
on parle de restauration de la nature
les propositions qui ne prenaient pas en
compte l'effort qui est de plusieurs
siècles des pays qui ont le risque
incendie depuis longtemps d'avoir des
zones tampons là où il y a des
habitations puisque ce sont des
négligences humaines qui créent les
incendies si on crée une zone où les
incendies ont du mal à démarrer et bien
ça protège les grands feux contre les
grands feux et c'est tout ce qui se
passe dans le sud de la France avec les
bois morts qui sont enlevés sur des
zones tampons de 100 mètres c'est très
important que le sud amène tout ce que
on a fait autour de cette protection du
risque incendie qui est
essentielles juste que moi je pense et
je pense que les citoyens en Europe
c'est que l'Europe fait véritablement
faire une différence sur les questions
climatiques et la biodiversité et là on
est en train d'entendre des leaders
différents et de de la droite ici aussi
dans la maison qui est maintenant ça
suffit un petit peu il faut freiner ça
mais au contraire toute la situation
qu'on vit montre qu'il faut faire plus
et font plus faire en sorte que cette
transition soit juste parce que sinon on
n'a pas les citoyens avec nous et donc
moi j'utilise et dévastée quand on est
en train de freiner ce travail monsieur
miguelès est-ce que on doit prendre
l'habitude de vivre avec ses incendies
et ce que finalement on doit se réformer
parce que le changement climatique il
est en train d'arriver
je pense qu'on ne doit pas c'est
résigner à ces problèmes et je suis tout
à fait d'accord qu'il faut voir ces
problèmes avec une ouverture et intégrer
différentes politiques le fait de forêt
son expression d'un problème très
complet avec beaucoup de facteurs il
faut tout s'adresser et du point de vue
de mécanisme de la protection civile
européenne qui est là pour protéger les
citoyens européens les propriétés
l'environnement aussi avec d'autres
services de l'Union et tous les États
membres et je pense qu'on peut on peut
arriver à réduire d'abord les risques et
d'améliorer cette réponse à travers une
fédération une fédéralisation des
ressources des travailleurs ensemble on
sera plus fort et on sera moins
vulnérable réduire les risques qu'on
utilisant notamment de nouvelles
technologies de nouveaux outils l'outils
de surveillance satellitaire Copernicus
il permet de faire des cartes très
précises des risques incendies il a été
mis en place il y a une dizaine d'années
est-ce que ça change la donne dans la
lutte contre les feux de forêt tout à
fait et on utilise ça pas seulement pour
les forêts mais pour chaque message et
les tremblements de terre les
inondations d'Italie et Turquie et on
fait un axe on met un accent très fort
sur la science sur la technologie on
veut vraiment bien informé on veut
prévenir on veut être en alerte et on
veut aussi guider la réponse d'une façon
efficace une façon efficiente et les
outils satellitaires donnent une c'est
un instrument indispensable et aussi
parce qu'on peut tracer pas seulement
faire une cartographie de problèmes mais
aussi des dangers on peut suivre avec
des
syndics des risques on peut orienter les
pays membres aussi où les problèmes
émergent là en ce moment on voit que les
centres de l'Europe les Nord de l'Europe
sont aussi atteints d'un risque réel des
feux
on sait que les agriculteurs ils sont en
train de se doter aussi un peu de ces
outils de pointe pour surveiller
justement ce climat changeant ces
risques d'incendie ces températures trop
fortes oui bien sûr les les agriculteurs
dans leur activité ont souvent des
petites stations météo ou des choses
comme ça mais ils ont surtout accès aux
données climatiques qui donnent des
informations sur la sécheresse des sols
en surface sur l'ensemble des risques
les pompiers aussi ça permet de savoir
que c'est à cet endroit là qu'on a un
risque et d'essayer collectivement de le
diminuer mais encore une fois je pense
vraiment il y a des pays qui vivent avec
les risques je pense par exemple le
Japon ils ont tellement de risques et
que toute la population est au courant
de si j'ai une météo qui me dit que j'ai
tel risque alors je ne prends pas je ne
mets personne en danger et nous je crois
que cette révolution là on a vraiment
besoin de la faire et que l'Union
européenne peut accompagner par exemple
le fait d'avoir une vraie journée de
sensibilisation aux risques dans notre
Union européenne pour que les gens
sachent quand il y a un risque incendie
fort je prends pas la voiture je fais
pas de travail avec quelque chose qui
peut créer une étincelle j'ai toujours
une bouteille d'eau dans ma voiture si
jamais je fais une étincelle pour
pouvoir l'éteindre les chiffres sont
clairs un feu qui est pris dans les 15
premières minutes il ne dépasse pas 4000
mètres carrés à partir de 400 hectares
on commence à avoir des feux qui sont à
maîtrisables et des grands feux mais les
mots de la fin est-ce qu'il faut plus de
sensibilisation je pense que je vais
être un peu provocatrice ici je pense
que évidemment on peut faire des
campagnes de sensibilisation on peut
faire des petits machins des petites
dépliants etc mais ce qui compte on a
des législateurs ici au Parlement
européen on a des collègues législateurs
avec les États membres notre travail
c'est de dire aux citoyens on a fait
telois telle loi et tes lois qui va
protéger et faire une nature et un
climat qui va pas être aussi vulnérable
au feu c'est ça il se brûle au Canada ça
brûle en Suède on va tous
brûler sauf si on fait des lois qui sont
là pour nous protéger dans la long terme
et pour faire baisser la charge de CO2
vous l'avez très bien expliqué merci à
vous d'avoir bien illustré ce débat
merci bien sûr à noter les spectateurs
de nous avoir suivis et vous restez sur
nos antennes pour la suite des
programmes
[Musique]